m
bonjour à tous je suis ici quils les tec
tec aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
l'argent public savez vous de quoi il
s'agit alors c'est quoi l'argent public
l'action publique également appelée le
trésor public et l'ensemble des moyens
financiers dont dispose un état cet
argent doit servir à fournir des
services publics indispensables au bon
fonctionnement d'une société développée
comme l'éducation la santé les services
sociaux l'environnement la sécurité dans
la construction et l'entretien
d'infrastructures et cetera des d'où
provient l'argent public l'argent public
dont dispose l'état il finissait par
tous les citoyens il est recueilli
notamment par le biais de prélèvements
obligatoires comme les impôts et les
cotisations sociales grâce à cette
participation collective
l'accès à de nombreux services rendus
par les pas sont gratuits et au bénéfice
de tous fait concrètement à quoi sert
l'argent public l'argent public sert à
remplir trois grandes fonctions la
première permet le développement et la
cohésion sociale du pays par le biais de
divers domaines comme l'éducation la
recherche la sécurité intérieure et
extérieure la santé la protection de
l'environnement des infrastructures et
cetera la deuxième fonction est de
corriger les inégalités ont donnant
accès au citoyen à des prestations
sociales retraites assurance maladie
indemnisation du chômage par exemple
enfin la troisième fonction consiste à
agir sur l'activité économique du pays
l'argent public a donc un but d'intérêt
général
à la rue nous aussi l'argent public a
permis de financer partiellement
certaines infrastructures utiles au
développement de l'île par exo qui via
le centre aquatique à pau nord à saint
denis ou encore l'embellissement des
lieux publics comme le jardin de l'état
mais aussi les collèges ou même la route
des tamarins qui a permis l'amélioration
de là circulation des véhicules et
qu'ils sont les acteurs des finances
publiques les acteurs des finances
publiques sont tous les organismes
financés par les prélèvements sur les
ressources des français il s'agit de
l'état des organismes de protection
sociale d'organismes d'administration
centrale et sociale et de l'union
européenne pourquoi les finances
publiques font tel débat les finances
publiques de la france comme de nombreux
pays sont régulièrement mises à mal les
contribuables pense qu'il manque de
clairvoyance sur certaines dépenses de
l'état aussi des dépenses très élevées
dans les ministères sont discutés par la
population quantique et des
constructions aléatoire dans certaines
villes qu'ils n'en voient pas l'utilité
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est l'argent public je vous dis à
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode